Can you explain why my research, CBC tests, my local
seat, this person is in another country.
So it's a different spelling.
So this leukocytes was 2.57 in the average rate is 4 to 10.8.
My basic bills, monophils, lymphocytes.
So your leukocytes are your total white blood cell.
So that's a combination of your lymphocytes,
your neutrophils, your basophils, your monocytes.
Those could all be within normal rate.
But you could have a total overall white blood cell
count that's a little low.
So what can you do to increase your total white blood cell count?
You really hear what increases your total white blood
cell count is is dealing with what could lower your total white
blood cell count.
So what can lower your total white blood cell count is chronic
infection.
So an acute infection, you'll have an elevated white blood cell
count, chronic infection, you could have a suppressed white blood
cell count.
You're also going to have a suppressed white blood cell
count with a different leukemia.
That's not uncommon either.
But if your basophils, your monocytes, your lymphocytes are within
normal ranges.
And I think your neutrophils are in normal range as well.
Then you think of just some chronic issues, maybe a chronic
ill infection, a chronic parasitic infection.
So what you would do is try to deal with that and investigate
a little further on dealing with that.
I know this person is going to be back in the states sometimes
soon.
It might be who you to get some different testing to see what
would be appropriate in this case.
So we might want to set up a one-on-one with me.
Well, we're some positive testing that we might want to move forward
a bit.
Also, what are your thoughts about the effects of dark chocolate,
the calcium absorption?
I have osteoporosis and osteopoeia,
according to the dextascade two years ago.
And heard that chocolate, it appears with calcium absorption
and the reactions.
Well, it really depends on what you're eating.
I don't think that eating a little bit of dark chocolate on a daily
basis is going to make a big deal with calcium absorption.
Good dark dark chocolate has a lot of antioxidants in it
and could actually be good for you.
You can satisfy a little bit of your sweet tunes if you're trying
to stay away from sugar.
So I wouldn't be too concerned about that.